so far hundreds of local women who are
either underinsured or uninsured have
received financial help for their
mammograms but there's still a lot more
money available in tonight's buddy check
8 report those funds come from an
unlikely source
[Music]
just about the time lauren kennedy was
ready for her first mammogram she was
out of work and uninsured set you in a
place to like look at your resources a
little bit differently and accept like
help in a way it had never even had to
do before luckily she learned about a
program to cover the cost kay's power
play was created by golden knights
player shea theodore to honor his
grandmother who died from breast cancer
we were very fortunate to have the
partnership with shea theodore and that
his grandmother had been seen as a
patient here and that he had a real
passion for helping out women that that
need help getting breast cancer care i
think when you have the option to like
take it free it kind of incentivizes you
to go ahead and do that even if it
sounds scary in partnership with susan g
komen there are thousands of dollars
available to help women pay for their
mammography as an added bonus this month
the mammal cup patch inspired by playoff
patches will be given to those
completing their annual exam this is
what the program is all about is
increasing that access no matter who has
their mammogram at the participating
partners here at the breast center at
sunrise you will get one of these
patches kennedy was one of the first to
benefit from kaye's power play and
admits it's only deepened her
appreciation for the team and its star
defenseman just the fact that he just
wanted to do this so that people in the
local community which i love anything
that has to that stays in las vegas
which made me feel like even more in
love with the team and him and just
everything that they're doing
so a total of a hundred thousand dollars
in new funding has been added to kaye's
power play thanks to theodore and the
vegas golden knights foundation plus
comprehensive cancer centers also kicks
in 500
based on every point that theodore
scores during the season so we do have
details on how to qualify on our buddy
check page at 8newsnow.com